this episode is presented by the new
action-adventure game undermine discover
the secrets of the undermine one peasant
at a time available today on Steam this
summer we're getting honest about summer
blockbusters past and present this is
honest trailers blockbusters summer from
the creative team who killed Al Custis
waters and Spider Man comes the
quirkiest revenge porn ever made the
beginning of the script was law angry
Johnnie Beckman [ __ ] stop 500 days of
summer strap in for a rom-com that's
right on both Rahm and calm because it's
more of a coming-of-age drama except the
guy who's coming of age is like 30 that
has you time-traveling through a
relationship like at we Christopher
Nolan because if you took out the
gimmick and watch these scenes in order
you'd see it's about a codependent
stalker and the empty vessel he latches
on to run meet Tom a screenwriter
stand-in with a boring job wrote this
one Mazel Tov on your Bar Mitzvah it's a
big seller a bowling dream I studied to
be an architect to awful friends you
don't believe that a woman could enjoy
being free and independent are you a
lesbian did you bang her know what hum
job no handle man no six cardigans seven
sweater vests and 500 days to treat this
girl like a series of video game
achievements to unlock for sex he
wondered if anyone else had made it this
far
yes meet summer she's a woman summer
Finn was a woman
[Music]
but back to Tom watch his heartbreak
when summer suddenly reveals she doesn't
want a boyfriend and by suddenly I mean
the first time they hang out Co
boyfriend no or not
and every time afterwards were you
looking for anything but that won't stop
Tom from declaring her the love of his
life no don't pull that with me because
they share the same values there's no
such thing as love it's fantasy it's
love it's not Santa Claus because they
mutually respect one another roses are
red violets are blue hue ah because he
thinks she's hot and she likes to
important stuff
[Music]
you used to call me anal girl so gather
round for a ten-year-old fill that much
like a ten-year-old relationship you
loved it when it was new but now it's
uncomfortable to revisit you cringe and
how service-level it was and you're
desperate to scrub your affection for
Tom from the internet but as time goes
on one thing remains clear the ending is
titanically stupid 'madam and I'm done
with this story I know who you did last
summer the previous girl
the snozzberries taste like snozzberries
Hit Girl please just beat this losers
ass chill Coulson yeah I am Minka six
seasons in a movie Puma yeah the Puma
cuz you know no I don't know do you go
dongs Pumas do Pumas have big dongs and
how would you know weird love well
actually
I'm Adam oh no Tom you know what that
means winter is coming
this episode was presented by the new
action adventure game undermine discover
the secrets of the undermine one peasant
at a time available today on Steam I
have the power stop touching my cat's
cookies smoochy blue cheese on the Fuji